a group of blind men heard that a
strange animal called an elephant had
been brought to the town but none of
them were aware of its shape or form so
they tried to find it and when they
found it started touching it to feel how
it looks like the first person whose
hand landed on the trunk said this being
is like a thick snake for another one
whose hand reached its ear it seemed
like a kind of a fan another person who
touched its leg said the elephant is a
pillar like a tree trunk the blind man
who placed his hand upon its side said
the elephant is a wall another who felt
its tail described it as a rope the last
felt its task stating the elephant is
like a spear this ancient sufi story is
a great way to introduce someone to the
core idea of systems thinking when we
mistake the parts for the whole we lose
perspective and miss the context in
which seemingly isolated events occur
especially when it comes to problem
solving and creative thinking
what we usually fail to grasp is that
the problem we face is part of a system
of problems and that also the problem
itself can be regarded as a system that
can be broken down into smaller problems
we are raised in an event-oriented
thinking world we see the world as a
complex succession of events rather than
as a system as a whole event-oriented
thinking assumes that each event we
experience
has a cause and that changing the cause
will correspondingly change the event
however that's the antithesis of how the
world functions famous systems thinker
donnella meadows writes in her book
thinking in systems a primer let's face
it the universe is messy it is
non-linear turbulent and chaotic it is
dynamic it spends its time in transient
behavior on its way to somewhere else
not in mathematically neat equilibria it
self organizes and evolves it creates
diversity not uniformity that's what
makes the world interesting that's what
makes it beautiful and that's what makes
it work understanding the endogenous
nature of systems and how they can shape
the fabric of our reality constitutes a
turning point in one's personal
development journey today i will attempt
to explain how a systems thinking
mindset can re-engineer the way one
approaches one's endeavors remember
always that everything you know and
everything everyone knows is only a
model get your model out there where it
can be viewed invite others to challenge
your assumptions and add their own this
is my model
when we look at the system rather than
comparing it to what we wanted to do and
then saying it is failing if it doesn't
do that we should instead look at what
it is doing well and then study how it
is designed to do that whenever you face
a setback or things don't go the way you
have planned there is absolutely no
reason to get discouraged let's say you
worked hard on a project but you
eventually failed your failure depends
on various reasons but that doesn't mean
that the system of working hard actually
failed while working hard on hard
problems you train your memory muscle
and you improve your analytical thinking
which results in overall better problem
solving ability eventually you will
succeed on a similar project and the
overall working system improves systems
thinking can help us see that
quote-unquote failing systems are
essentially a way to evolve our thinking
patterns
in our society most of the conundrums we
face are a consequence of our inability
to connect the dots in the relations
between our systems as donella meadows
writes in her book there are no separate
systems the world is a continuum let's
use an example from real life
in most countries the problem of
gank-related violence especially in
youngsters is usually attempted to be
solved by more policing because
event-oriented thinking suggests that
violence is solved by imposing order
however the problem of youngsters
joining gangs is often related to family
dysfunction and the family issues may be
related to unemployment and so on it is
a structural issue that requires a
systems thinking approach problems do
not occur in isolation but in relation
to each other this also applies to the
way we approach problem solving whenever
you feel frustrated by a problem you
face and you think you are never going
to reach
a solution try and think of other areas
that affect your problem let's say
you're facing social anxiety this is a
psychological issue that is
deeply rooted in the constitution and
psychological background of the
individual but it might also be a
byproduct of the environment that the
individual decides to inhabit maybe you
don't go out a lot maybe you don't
expose yourself to unfamiliar situations
maybe you don't partake in group
activities often enough systems thinking
can help us see that what may seem as an
isolated problem is actually part of an
interconnected network of related events
it is a critical alternative of systems
thinking to always learn from your
experiences regardless of their negative
or positive nature becoming aware of
what the system tells you every day is
an asset by learning how to evaluate the
feedback you get you develop an
awareness that allows you to learn from
what the system tells you in every
endeavor you embark on be constantly
aware of your accomplishments and try to
evaluate your progress on a regular
basis feedback coming from both yourself
and other people related to the endeavor
mainly experts not random outsiders is
endemic to the fruition of the endeavor
as you attempt to optimize the system
bear in mind that results after applying
feedback do not occur instantly you
can't navigate well in an interconnected
feedback dominated world unless you take
your eyes off short-term events and look
for long-term behavior and structure
unless you are aware of false boundaries
and bounded rationality unless you take
into account limiting factors
non-linearities and delays for instance
if we give a person medication and they
don't get better fast it would be
dangerous to give them more medication
instead of simply wait for the
medication to kick in understanding
these delays is important so that we
don't overreact during a lag period
thinking that no change is happening
when in fact it is just delayed we
usually have a bad tendency to judge
early whenever we attempt to change
something in our lives if we don't see
immediate results we get discouraged and
give up the idea of delay is crucial to
the system's thinking concept it takes
time to experience lasting optimized
results and this is an integral part of
any serious system
addiction is finding a quick and dirty
solution to the symptom of the problem
which prevents or distracts one from the
harder and longer term task of solving
the real problem whatever your personal
ambitions and goals might be when it
comes to systems thinking you need to
embrace long-term solutions instead of
quick and easy fixes long-term solutions
require the proper understanding of each
part 4. the stability of a system is
predicated on the harmony between the
parts that's such a crucial aspect of
personal development and that's why i
often suggest the adoption of a
generalist mindset the generalist
mindset urges you to delve into
different topics and eventually try to
develop an
interdisciplinary approach when it comes
to thinking and learning you start to
think in systems and this mode of
cognition leads you to deeper states of
consciousness that challenge the way you
interpret the world you become more
aware of your own existence your own
limitations and your own potential the
mechanics of the world start to make
sense and you start to perceive patterns
as philosopher isaiah berlin once said
to understand is to perceive patterns
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now